I imagine that "Born This Way" is a little bit about being yourself...
...and how to overcome bullies.
I don't know if you wanna talk a little bit.
A little bit.
What's so funny when I put that song out, because everybody was like,...
..."Oh, the lyrics are so literal."
And I'm like, "Yeah."
When, you know, when you get bullied, you kind of try to,...
...there's almost this like emotional poetry that you go through in high school.
"Oh well, someday..." and you just kind of try to hide from it and be the bigger person.
But "Born This Way" is about saying,...
..."This is who I am. This is who I am."
I mean the next single "Judas" is like this very classic Gaga record but...
...more importantly, the song "Born This Way" is this like gateway drug for the album.
And really trying to say in the most literal and honest way that I can,...
...that when I go to the Monster Ball, I see something so fearless and so special in my fans.
But I also see something afraid.
Something that I was.
Something that was unsure.
And I really encourage people to look into the darkness...
...and look into places that you would not normally look to find uniqueness and specialness...
...because that's where the diamonds are hiding.
I think that's a wonderful message.